wir haben jetzt die seite der
demonstranten gehört wir wollen aber
auch die seite der polizei hören und
dafür ist mir jetzt hör gerade
zugeschaltet von der gewerkschaft der
polizei guten tag herr dick vielleicht
können sie uns erklären wie bereitet
sich die polizei auf solch eine lage
überhaupt vor als nächstes mal ist das
keine besondere lage das ist grosse
menschenmenge ja aber es ist eine
veranstaltungs lage da wird ist vorher
kooperationsgespräche gegeben haben mit
dem veranstalter man wird darüber
gesprochen haben wie man das recht auf
meinungsfreiheit in zusammenhang mit der
versammlungsfreiheit durchsetzen wollen
weil die polizei ist wieder durch das
recht zuständig unabhängig welche
meinung dort vertreten wird gerade wie
es denn die möglichkeit auch jetzt
kurzfristig zu reagieren wir sehen es
sind offenbar deutlich mehr menschen als
erwartet welchen spielraum hat die
polizei da wie geht man da vor der spiel
und denkt ich bestehe schon darin dass
vorher klar war unter welchen auflagen
stattfinden kann
das heißt es müssen genügend ordner
vorhanden sein wir haben neben dem bild
gesehen dass die ordner auch die
informationen weiter gehen und das ist
eine wichtige information wenn die
polizei sagt hier ist es zu voll damit
man auch den menschen auch die
sicherheit geben
wir haben euch im blick wir wollen
verhindern dass es möglicherweise eine
panik deswegen ist auch diese durchsage
meint ihr ist es zu voll
die polizei reagiert ich sehe dass dort
polizeibeamte in die menschenmenge um
eben die abstände wieder einzuhalten
unter denen diese veranstaltung
genehmigt worden ist so wird man denkt
ich schlitz frische versuchen diese
versammlungsfreiheit zu gewährleisten
dazu gehört auch der mund nasen schutz
denn jetzt der polizei liege leider
offensichtlich angekündigt hat das
musste ich natürlich durch solch eine
menge durch schreiben bezieht das muss
mit lautsprecherdurchsagen auch vom
veranstalter bekannt gegeben werden
wir haben gesehen die menschen halten
sich daran nicht und es ist ja auch
genau das wogegen sie demonstrieren
nämlich gegen die korona regeln wie wird
der nächste schritt sein was erwarten
sie dort heute noch
also ich denke dass man sehr klug und
verhältnismäßig vorgehen wird
möglicherweise ist die am ende die
auflösung einer veranstaltung denn
beispielsweise zu viele menschen auf dem
veranstaltungs weg sind zu viele
menschen an einem veranstaltungsort sind
weil man ja auch für die sicherheit
dieser menschen verantwortlich ist und
da kann man nicht unbegrenzt einen
zulauf zu lassen denke dass das etwas
sein wird was am ende stehen wird und in
der zwischenzeit wird man immer wieder
an die auflagen unter denen diese
veranstaltung genehmigt worden ist wird
man immer wieder erinnern und mahnen
jeder versammlungsteilnehmer selbst hat
hier eine verantwortung wahr der
verpflichtung dass er auch auf wenn er
damit nicht einverstanden ist er kann ja
seine meinung gegen die kuh oder
auflagen kann er auch mit einer maske im
gesicht kultur es ist ein symbol was
damit verknüpft ist und ich denke dass
das auch das ziel ist dass über diese
symbolik versucht mit stimmung zu machen
wie ist ihre persönliche einschätzung
wird heute in berlin die lage noch
eskalieren und wenn ja wie geht die
polizei denn damit um
mein erster gedanke gilt natürlich an
meinen kollegen die auch unter der
suchen müssen und da aufbringen ihre
eigene körperliche unversehrtheit diese
auflagen durchzusetzen
ich hoffe und wünsche ich mir dass es
nicht zu einer eskalation kommt denn das
ist die voraussetzung die in der
verfassung steht dass die menschen in
deutschland friedlich gewaltfrei ihre
meinung äußern dürfen und dessen sollten
sich alle bewusst sein dass das was wir
hier erleben ausdruck ist von einer
gelebten demokratie und wir weit weg
sind von einer diktatur in einer
diktatur würden wir solche bilder
überhaupt nicht zu sehen bekommt das
haben wir ja den jüngsten tag auch aus
dem ausland gesehen
unsere bilder haben ja gezeigt wie die
beamten jetzt schon angeschrieben wurden
es wurde ja auch in den sozialen
netzwerken dazu aufgerufen wirklich
gewaltbereit gegenüber den beamten zu
sein
wie kann man darauf die beamten auch
psychisch vorbereiten dort die ruhe zu
bewahren
in der verstellung ist vollkommen
korrekt ist besondere verfiel das man
also hier denjenigen der mir die
freiheit ermöglicht meine meinung zu
sagen dass ich die geschicke des teams
und das für nicht besonders perfide
sollte ihm der respekt entgegen bringen
weil er doch die möglichkeiten schaffen
dass ich meine meinung sagen kann wir
versuchen das in gesprächen mit den
kollegen auf diese situation hinzuwirken
diese sogenannten hygiene die muss sind
ja für uns ein neuer bunten mix an
polizeilichen gegenüber da haben wir in
der vergangenheit mit den schwarzen
locken oder noch weiter zurück mit den
clowns angehen ja auch noch eine ganz
andere qualität aber hier ist gerade
dieser gesellschaft wieder bunte mix er
ist auch schwierig macht dort immer
wieder kommunikativ mit den menschen ins
gespräch zu kommen ja gerade von der
gewerkschaft der polizei ich dann gehen
ganz herzlich für dieses gespräch
dann gewählt